we talk about economics here all the
time on surveillance I'm not sure
sometimes how much I know in comparison
to the great economic theorists but how
much did you know before you began this
project about all I think like most of
America almost next to nothing you know
it's one of those where you have that
conversation about economics your eyes
glaze over your rolls guys roll back in
your head and you're like I should just
check out of this conversation so what
was the biggest takeaway for you well I
think the biggest takeaway for me is
that we as a population are kind of
economically illiterate and I think that
what these films do and what they start
to set up is a general conversation that
I think will hopefully enlighten all of
us in a way that that will help us you
know start to understand where we are as
a country and what we can do to move
forward so the concept of economics is
pretty broad there are lots of different
schools you had to decide which school
you were going to teach as well yeah
well the beauty of what we did is we had
ten different economic advisors who
basically came on all from different
schools of economic thought who
basically said if you're gonna has 20
questions about the economy here's what
you should be asking here's the
questions you should be trying to answer
and most second most economists will
agree to about eighty-five percent of
like here's what economics is about then
it starts to get into partisan politics
but I think there are eighty to
eighty-five percent of like core
economic values that is true you begin
this project about a year ago what was
the conversation you had with Paul
Allen's Vulcan productions that got them
involved as well well it was it was we
were developing a film about money about
explaining how many how many exists why
money has value and they heard we were
developing this film and said well Paul
really wants to demystify the economy to
educate the population in way that
really isn't happening and I said well
we should get together immediately and
out of that conversation came we the
economy 20 short films you can't afford
to miss can you do it with film I
watched the cage match between Simon
Kuznets and and you know that's a very
valid debate ever whether GDP is an
accurate measure of the economy or
whether we need to include other things
I don't know if I would have understood
that just from watching the film but I
think what the film does is it sets up a
great primer for a deeper conversation
or a deeper exploration I think the
biggest thing we want to do is at least
open the door to people understanding
how these things work this goes back to
ET and Spielberg talking about how they
did the keys with Peter Coyote the key
is walking through the woods how do you
jump-start science and they did it with
the keys dangling from the belt and
eighty and Gideon Rose this goes over
to your world of spurring the debate you
have Dean Baker that's right so anywhere
Dean Baker is one of the three or four
smartest guys in Washington creating
attention a sweat about this what's been
the response of people that have seen it
mean to the kids who want to go out and
say hey I want to read Gideon roses for
it appears that's the goal here III
think the goal is you want to get people
engaged in a way they never have been
and what's happened is you've got kids
who are watching you got parents who are
watching you have teachers who are using
this in a classroom now that is like the
greatest thing we get of our meal Gideon
ran away from the rear fight atmosphere
of the pH DS you do but this is
important oh absolutely look Ebola is
not gonna kill us stupidity is gonna
kick our cat Achilles stupidities gonna
kill us so anything that can be done to
introduce broader sectors the population
to the real trade-offs and questions and
debates and we treat people like they're
stupid but the fact is that you deal
with their soccer teams or their
baseball teams the football teams they
understand trade-off that's what
economics is all about that's right
educating people about the necessary
policy trade-offs you can't ever no free
lunch but you can have good or better
choices presents already writing it down
bolas not going to go to a stupid Jana I
came back one of the day ball is not
going to kill us stupidity is going to
kill right that's like the quote of the
day right right there now we've got it